all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back with the boys deer
becky part five now unlike the previous
ones we've done this is more
informational than anything else but
this is one of those instances where the
information we get is pretty critical so
what this does is it initially picks up
on a rooftop where of course you've got
vicar meeting with billy butcher now
remember the whole idea behind this is
that vicar is basically their eyes and
ears while they're there and they're
relying on the information that vicar's
giving them to help them understand
what's going on with julian baxter pugh
the scorchers and the inner turmoil
that's taking place inside vaude
american now here's a funny thing here
right that's how vicar understands it
the reality is that billy butcher
doesn't truly trust vicar there really
isn't a whole lot of indication that
what's going on or at least that what
vicar's telling him is something that he
can just wholeheartedly believe and so
what they did is they actually planted a
bug on vicar himself he doesn't know
about it but basically it's there to
hear everything that vicar hears and so
when vicar comes to billy butcher and
says hey man like here's what's going on
here's what i heard yada yada they would
know if he was lying or not right so
it's a pretty genius maneuver there it's
a pretty cool thing because what it does
is it maintains the loyalties of vicar
albeit without his knowledge and it
gives them the ability to always ensure
that he's being honest and to counter
correctly if he's not and so what ends
up happening from what vicar tells him
is that what ends up happening is there
is a point where he overheard basically
a conversation or really more of an
argument between julian baxter pugh and
stormfront so that they could have some
kind of a conversation that vicar can't
necessarily make out but that stormfront
kept getting pissed off and kept saying
no but he said it in a way that
indicated he said it before and he was
pissed off about having to say it again
and so while all that's going on you've
of course got mother's milk who's
basically listening to all the
information or all the audio that was
captured by vicar without his knowledge
and just kind of running through
everything and so once vicar leaves
right when the question's kind of asked
here by billy butcher like is there
anything else like anything else that
you want to tell us anything else that
you want to let us know about that
you're maybe keeping away or anything
like that you know like anything you can
tell us about stormfront that vicar's
response is i mean i kind of thought
that was all you'd really want to know
like i don't think you really want to
know anything else and he kind of asks a
few things really you know when he goes
in to meet with stormfront he's like you
know who's the brit guy and you know
stormfront's like you know just some
some piece of crap or something like
that and stormfront basically dismisses
vicar once he realizes it is vicar so
obviously stormfront doesn't take vicar
very seriously but he's like after what
i overheard now i'm here to talk to you
about it and the reality is that when
when vicar leaves mother mother's mocha
is just kind of like yep he was
basically telling the truth you know i
mean stormfront called him a sucker a
few times but outside of that like he's
basically telling the truth and so
that's when you get into this sort of
realization a revelation of what's going
on and that mother's milk says okay so
like stormfront figures superhuman
development is a better bet than julian
baxter pugh's division he doesn't want
to be part of anything that can connect
him to like the grand savannah like all
this stuff he says and billy butcher of
course responds by saying i don't think
we're going to be hearing from
stormfront i reckon the big square heads
basically rattled right like with
everything going on he's going to be
playing it pretty low profile and so
when the question's asked by by mother's
milk do you think that like what's
actually going on here is vicar went in
there and said hey uh i need you guys to
basically act i need you guys to kind of
put on a show because i'm basically
being tracked down or being used by the
boys and they know about us right the
jig is up and all that kind of stuff the
responsibility butcher is no that's
that's not what's really going on at all
because the reality here is that if
vicker would go in there and he were to
tell vod american or stormfront or
julian baxter pugh or those guys that
were on them that were basically forcing
him to work as a spy they would just
kill him and walk away right they
wouldn't they wouldn't put on some great
big huge elaborate show or anything like
that that's just too much work right
they would just execute him and it would
be done the fact that he's even here and
talking to us indicates that they don't
know that we're on to them and if they
do know they're keeping it very very low
key but there's nothing to indicate they
do because all this information is being
gathered and so again the main focus
here of the boys at the moment under
colonel mallory is to basically go
through and to ensure or to allow the
campaign with julian baxter pugh to go
through because remember julian baxter
puke what he's basically trying to do
here is launch his own superhero
development
system right his own superhero
development project kind of within vaude
american itself vaude american is
keeping an eye on it but because of the
popularity and the fact that the
scorchers were just immediately made
high profile means that it forces the
hand of odd american to kind of stay
away fat american can't just go through
and just kill the scorchers all of a
sudden because then julian baxter puke
having all the information that he has
could actually dump that information out
to the world so it's really kind of
corporate politics is going on that's
how this inner turmoil plays out and so
while the scorchers are kind of there
doing their thing that we end up finding
out that what julian baxter pugh had
done is he had actually hired some
actors that are basically supposed to go
out there and face off against the
scorchers in order to put on this show
this kind of mock conflict or whatever
so the scorchers can be put out there as
basically a superhero team of sorts but
because vlad american can't act publicly
what what vaude american intends to do
is send in their their own superheroes
to act quietly right to basically kill
the scorchers off so no one really knows
what's going on now in reality because
julian baxter pugh's media division is
here what would likely happen is these
seedless heroes or seedless super beings
would also kill that media division
right because it's all being recorded
but none of it's really being live
streamed so that's the thing to
understand here is there's multiple
forces at work now billy butcher and
them right billy coming to the
realization that with stormfront being
tipped off by by julian baxter pugh or
at least being aware of what pug wants
to do likely told the superhero division
of vaude american which is why these
supes are here in the first place and so
with billy butcher and even even colonel
mallory realizing that it's okay we've
got to make sure this thing goes off
without a hitch that's why they're here
is to take out the seedless superheroes
before they can stop the actors from
getting to the scorchers and allowing
this video to go off without a hitch
right this whole plan of julian baxter
puke because the more infighting there
is in vaude american the better it is
for the boys and the easier for them to
get in and start bringing down vaude
american from the inside out right
hopefully they they believe it'll lead
to some kind of a major collapse and so
what goes on is that as the boys are
here inside the stadium you've got the
actors who they have no idea what
they're actually in for like they would
probably all end up being killed but the
boys start making their way through and
they confront the superheroes right the
sea less superheroes and so in front of
all these actors the boys beat the
superheroes to death they literally kill
them all in the most brutal way ever
even the actors are just kind of like
wow like this is insane like they just
beat these guys to death now where the
actors are kind of like okay this is not
what we signed up for we were told all
of this was going to be going on out
there in on on the field what in the
hell is happening right now you know
like are you guys working for for julian
baxter puget the response to the boys is
uh yeah yeah we're here for julian
baxter puke these guys were going to do
yen but we're working for julia julian
baxter puke so here's what you're going
to do you're going to go out there and
you're going to play your role and while
they're like i mean no like we are not
doing that like this is not what we
signed up for the response to the boys
is either you can die here or you can go
out there right but like we're here
working for julian baxter puke do not
tell him what went on in here he doesn't
like wrinkles and plans so as far as
you're concerned you got suited up you
went out there and that was basically it
so what's it going to be right are you
going to die here or are you going to
play are you going to live and play your
role out there and for no other reason
the action of self-preservation
they end up going out there and they end
up basically facing off against the
scorchers and seemingly the whole thing
goes off without a hit so again this is
a much shorter video than the ones that
we normally record again it's more
informational than anything else but
it's just kind of them executing that
plan so the kind of tail bit that we get
here is basically billy butcher going
through again continuing to write in
this journal and saying that he hates
all the superheroes now this is where he
really starts to show his true colors
when he says it's not just the one that
did what he did to becky right the one
that knocked becky up and resulted in
her giving birth to a superpowered baby
and dying in the process he says it's
basically all of them it's every single
superpower being out there the good guys
the bad guys the ones that have no idea
what they're really getting into right
like the the starlights of the world
right those wide-eyed you know young
naive superheroes out there in heartland
america who want nothing more than to be
a part of the seven that they're all the
problem right they're all a major issue
it's this broad stroke on just the evil
nature of anybody with powers and that
they all have to go every single one of
them have to die which again this all
sets the stage for why billy is the way
he is by the time we pick up with the
main boys story so with that being said
guys again this is much much shorter
than usual but more of an informational
episode thank you all for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace